welcome back to new rock stars this is
the big question the show that gives you
way too much information about evil
books
and how we can use them to curse our
enemies or maybe even you know our
co-hosts
speaking of i'm philip molina and my
co-host this week is tommy birchtoll
yeah so close close enough
it was tommy b all along
[Laughter]
it's been a week tommy please stop
singing that tommy how are you i'm good
long time no see
good to see you as always i like your
shirt thank you i designed it i know
i like it from the epic hero shop you
can check uh this one out it's part of
the unusual couple collection
and it's augmented reality yes did i
send you one did i forget to send you
one
no you said that you wanted to hand it
to me in person when we're reunited and
that it was only going to be appropriate
if you could hand it to me via t-shirt
hug
which i think was a phrase you coined
but that i trademarked
it's when you want a hug and instead i
throw a t-shirt in its arms yeah
and she restrained me with the shirt so
i can't reach your ass
up tommy you forgot to ask how i'm doing
phillip how the hell are you
i'm not doing great tommy okay i just
lost internet for a long time
and during that time uh people can see
this on my twitter it's true
i discovered that in my bathroom i just
moved into this new house
the walls uh were painted uh
but they were not cleaned before they
were painted and so the previous
tenant's hair
is painted into the walls uh editors uh
you can
you can show a picture of this
disgusting art piece
so so then what i'm hearing is my spells
are working
hairy walls hairy walls trap
phillip inside your halls
wrap him up in your tenuous fibers
something something watch macgyver
friday nights on cbs
all right speaking of spells uh tommy
was only supposed to say hi during that
but
we just really got off there uh guys one
division the series has given us an
expanded view of the mcu's version of
magic wanda's powers are increasingly
becoming more
witchy as she heads toward being the
scarlet witch e
and agnes has now been confirmed to be a
witch from the comics agatha harkness
uh who's maybe becoming a violet witchy
maybe well you can see she's got all the
great classic witch stuff she's got the
underground
dungeon uh lair she got the weird frizzy
hair
she got a creepy magic book yes
that's what we're talking about tommy i
think this leads into
the question that you had for me who is
my real father no
i chuzzle buzz chuzzlebuzz on twitter
which is your real fun that is not my
chuzzlebuzz is not my burner account
chuzzlebuzz asks this question which i
also have
what is the dark hold and are there
real-life books of magic
okay the dark hold we
saw what potentially is the dark hole
in agatha's lair and
we've seen the dark cold actually a
couple of times in marvel properties
but right now this if this is the dark
cold
it's the first time we're seeing it in
the stuff that we count sorry agents of
shield sorry
run away sorry everything else all right
but the dark hold is this ancient book
of spells of
unspeakable power right the book is made
uh itself from dark matter from the hell
dimension in the comics
the dark hold was written by you how do
you say this chatham
i think it's chasing jason let's get
down from there
let go of your sister ragness okay so
so chaithan jathan was a uh demonic
elder uh god and earth's first
practitioner black magic basically
honestly it's like a ripoff of cthulhu
yes
but uh still it's it's love crafty and
we'll kind of get back to that in a bit
um but chatham put all of his knowledge
of magic
into the dark hold on is also
technically the source of
wanda's power in the comics so
in the mcu like i said we've seen it in
uh agents of shield and runaways
but by the time you watch this it might
have been revealed that this is
actually the official version of the
dark hole confirmed in the main mcu
timeline are there other real-life books
of magic out there
besides the boxcar children which are a
magical adventure
in every book as a family of orphan
children
growing up in a boxcar solve mysteries
you know in some ways
every book has a magical ability to take
you to a whole new world
the more you know
so i that that's a quick summary on what
the dark hold is but
there are other famous books of magic
and a really big
inspiration for marvel's darkhold is and
technically it also exists in marvel but
also this outside of marvel
is the necronomicon oh yeah they have
they have that every year in san diego
right
metronomicon yes everybody dresses uh
they get together and they get their
novels huge celebrities samuel l jackson
he's usually there
sometimes it's like brian cranston will
dress up in a costume and no one knows
who he is
lots of fun stuff so uh that book uh
[Music]
the necronomicon a lot of people think
it's a real thing
it actually was invented by who i
referenced earlier the horror author
h.p lovecraft uh in the 1920s and then
it's appeared in a bunch of other stuff
like uh evil dead and just
all over the place in some versions it's
actually like bound inside of human
flesh and reading it for too long will
make you insane yes
kind of like my co-host bound in flesh
and will drive you insane and if you
read me for too long there's a d
you'll go insane don't mind if i don't
[Music]
no it's just in case i forget uh what
the letter d is
i've had it since i was 20. i'm 22 now
so i guess it's not that new
all right and there's some other
examples of these fictional magic books
right the king and yellow that they
reference in a true detective
um a compendium of common curses
uh and their counteractions from harry
potter and also the book of eternity
from dc comics but
what about magical books in our own
timeline this is where i had a lot of
fun
uh turning off the lights and doing what
i do on the computer
oh fast wait a second oh god thank god
oh i thought you're gonna need to put in
your expressvpn for a second
these uh magical textbooks they're known
as grimoires
it's a concept of these magical kind of
spell books you just call them a
grimoire
uh so we can actually just examine a few
of these real ones
and also what magical secrets uh we can
maybe divine right here on big question
number one a book of shadows
they spooked yes oh yes i'm always
afraid of shadows my own particularly
it's so big and when you see it it means
that uh we'll get six more weeks of
horny loneliness
i was gonna say something i was gonna
take the name every time it's you
i'm always gonna say something that will
have the fbi
fbi player
every time so i have to like cut myself
off
i appreciate that thank you so a book of
shadows is a collection of religious
texts uh and just like
uh instructions for magical rituals um
but it's used in wicca
right the the concept of uh like which
religion kind of
and then in a other a bunch of other
pagan practices it contains the core
rituals
magical practices uh ethics philosophy
of the practitioner but
uh the book from the tv show charmed
which i know you were a huge uh enemy of
was an example of a book of shadows
right
their book could defend itself from harm
using its own magical powers
there's also book of shadows mentioned
in the film the craft and also a sequel
to blair witch
called book of shadows blair witch 2. so
there's no defining just like
one definitive book of shadows but a
person actually
creates their own personal book of
shadows a slam book viewer
uh to record knowledge that you're
acquiring as you learn
so technically there's a book of shadows
in the movie mean girls
absolutely that's probably the original
one this girl
is the nastiest
skank [ __ ] i've ever
met so it because it does hold your
personal feelings
it's usually in regard to your wiccan
and which life
uh but it's also a written
representation of you or in other words
of your shack so there's a famous book
of shadows and that's one
created by uh this english wiccan gerald
gardner
uh sometime probably in like the late
40s or early 50s you know that like
creepy time hey jerry what are you
writing there nothing my book of shadows
don't worry about me oh chap
hey jerry come off it and watch the
footy match i'm gonna put you in my book
of shadows right now
that's why i went but it's not it's it's
still a mean girl's book
philip molina is a tosser i was the
other guy
yeah you were the whole time you
couldn't tell by my perfect impression
of you
i love my watching me footy so this
guy's basically considered to be the
father
of like modern wiccan and try to keep
all of this uh
the content of his books of shadow
secret but they were
published in the 70s and 80s because it
was free love and everybody just wanted
to get weird
and so the full text eventually made its
way onto the internet
in the 1990s well no one ever abuses
things that make their way onto the
internet so i'm sure it'll
be just fine tommy yes we all know what
you actually do on the internet
i sell illegal insects all over the
world
on tommy tube everyone knows you use
your expressvpn to get to my page
and i'll sell you a grub worm from
ecuador that you're not supposed to have
i want you to think
about something dark that
a book of shadows would be used for that
you want to happen
and then we're going to use the witch's
chant from gardner's book of shadows to
try to make it happen
why don't you tell me what it is but
we'll bleep it out so that uh we can't
use this
against you in court all right i want
to rise to be the most powerful
terrible food poisoning next season
coming up
even children no no just the teams just
the teams
you ready so be thinking on that
darksome night and shining moon east and
south and west and north
park into the witch's ruin here come i
call the
fourth yes can't be stopped now
earth and water air and fire wand and
pinnacle and sword
work unto my desire hearken ye unto my
word
yes grows more powerful with each verse
why all the power of land and sea by all
the might of moon and sun what is my
will so mote it be
what i do say it shall be done
speaking of done are done because the
are going all the way baby so this is
basically a
this is a nursery rhyme and i swear
by the moon and the sun and the fire
my baby it's like a bone addiction and i
can't deny
won't you tell me is it healthy baby did
you know
that when it snows my
and the light baby
i compare you to a kiss from you on this
yes don't worry we bleeped out some of
tommy's words there too
so you won't be cursed by seals cursed
by a seal on a grave
tommy how do you feel i think i just
charmed you
i feel good i feel like i'm completely
in control
nothing too spooky happening and i
give my life in service to you my dark
master
your words are my bidding your bidding
you're my actions
uh all right key of solomon is there's
another famous real life magic book
it's called the key of solomon it was
written sometime in the 14th or 15th
century so this is way further back uh
this is like the italian renaissance
the key of solomon is a grimoire uh
claiming to contain
some of biblical magic jesus magic if
you will
you've come i have and it's utilized
uh by historical figures like king
solomon
so the magic in the key of solomon
derives its power from
god like that god right
so this is like old biblical power it's
so epic so important that it was
recently featured in a dan
brown novel talk about a dark artist
quick
i'd name your five favorite dan brown
tropes
okay uh secret family members yeah uh
wait way too young woman for uh way old
man
a physically deformed person who is a
bad guy
a police officer who seems like they're
a bad guy but ends up being a good guy
yeah
gross description of a naked religious
old man
yes there you go he loved describing
old naked men it's a real passion of his
yeah and mine
the old frenchman pierre was
self-flagellating
when the very young but still legal
girl 18 years old and one day
vanessa cassadine sauntered into the
room
anyway but anywho according to mythology
solomon wrote the book for his son
rehoboam which you might remember
westworld season three
so the book was supposed to be hidden in
king solomon's tomb upon his death but
legend has it the book was discovered
actually by some babylonian philosophers
while repairing his tomb
and one of these men received a vision
wanda vision
all right so one of these guys received
a vision in which a supposed angel
commanded him to
hide the book from the unworthy
this has happened to me before when i
was in 10th grade an angel came to me
and told me to hide my algebra brook
so that i couldn't do my algebra test i
told my teacher that it was a
heavenly force that had made me
unprepared for the time so the book is
actually divided into two books the
first book
is full of conjurations and invocations
and curses
to summon and constrain spirits of the
dead and demons
it can also tell you how to become
invisible by the way that book i find
hidden treasures
become popular which is something
solomon was very worried about i'll help
you be popular
also find the love of your life this is
just a ym magazine with a quiz on how to
find a boyfriend right but
again with old uh god power i like that
this is set up like a tick tock where
like
hey what's up everybody it's tommy b and
i'm gonna tell you how to find hidden
treasure become popular
and find the love of your life like for
part two part two details how the
operator should purify themselves
through exorcism what clothing they
should wear
instructions for building magical
instruments
uh that you have to use to perform the
spells or like i don't know a sick ass
salute and then there's also the uh
the necessary animal sacrifices that you
have to do to appease the spirits
which like why why are they such a dicks
anyway let's try what's what's a spell
that lives in your head rent free
it's uh the how to render thyself master
of a treasure possessed by the spirits
spell oh so what is something you want
oh
most definitely o.j simpson's heisman
trophy okay you had that ready to go
all right all right repeat after me
adona hi elohim
i don't know hi elohim
existence of existences have mercy upon
me and cast my eyes upon thy servant
princes of princesses princesses of
tides
bonjourno principesa cast your eyes upon
me and cast your irons
upon your pants peter pan the boy who
never grew
oh ye angels and spirits of the stars oh
all ye angels and elementary spirits oh
all ye spirits present before the face
of god
i.d minister faithful servant of the
most high conjuring he
let god himself the existence of
existences conjuring you to come and be
present at this operation
oh
gods and monsters friends and lovers
we are gathered here today to celebrate
the union of kermit the frog and miss
piggy
and holy matrimony amen a woman
i didn't hear a single thing in there
about me getting a prize
i think this is just a pyramid scheme
for god to get to go on vacation hear ye
hear ye like god are you interested in
like hanging out
maybe we can hang out or something hey
what's up god i know the whole coven
thing has everyone freaked out but we
thought we could get together at a park
in burbank
and just have like a socially distanced
hang kick a soccer ball around totally
happy
to meet my dog nearby yeah everyone be
massed up but we will remove our masks
for snacking and kissing
fire fire ignite within me just as i
am forever sad all right up next the
sworn book of
onorius so this is a medieval grimoire
supposedly
written by onorius of thieves the book
is one of the oldest existing and most
influential medieval grimoires dating
back to the 14th century
uh johann hartlieb is a physician
from that time which like positions from
that time by the way
not much more than wizards
and it was used in your favorite
necromancy
oh yeah and a fellow necro
congratulations brother the sworn book
of an aurius was supposedly compiled by
a group of magicians
close-up magic who were hanging out
siegfried roy penn teller david
copperfield
so it's group of magicians that were
being persecuted by the catholic church
be gone such and they wanted to get all
of their knowledge collected into a
singular
book so their students were sworn to
secrecy before being given access to
this book
cross your heart do it
my adventure and if they owned a copy
they had to be buried with it the book
is a slender little 93 chapters long
like a dan brown novel just like a
classic dan brown novel way too many
chapters it covers a variety of topics
from
avoiding purgatory to once again finding
treasures
and most importantly of course conjuring
and commanding demons
come ye all who are
bearded fellows join across
the internet internet what
wait a second i think i got it i think i
i think
power in the money money and the power
minute after minute hour after hour
tell me why are we so blind to see that
the ones we hurt are you
and me oh that was great how do you feel
i feel like i've summoned a demon that's
for sure
and treasure can't be far up next the
gold rub
i like that's my favorite named one so
far because it reminds you of that girl
you dated
yes the golder brock jones
i also said the name of a real
ex-girlfriend and i was like that would
have gone over horribly
so then i just went with jones a real
ex-girlfriend named galdriva
like her last name but uh it was her
first name was
moss all right so this this grammar
comes from uh
uh iceland in the 16th century it
contains 47 spells it's
from a different a range of magicians
this time they got a mix
uh involves the spellcaster speaking and
incantation out loud
or you could carve runes into objects if
you're angry
[Music]
some of the spells in the golden block
deal with a wide variety of issues
people face back in medieval times like
in iceland uh catching a
thief curing headaches and insomnia
protecting your favorite horse which
still a problem hasn't been there
uh and again winning the love of a
person still a problem
and then there's like super dark ones
right like to cause fear in your enemies
and
to kill someone's livestock or give
someone flatulence
oh god that would be fun you could
prevent a woman from speaking
again it's weird it's like when a group
of magicians hang out
or super misogynistic silence women uh
what's the most important thing to keep
women quiet
be gone so okay we're gonna try a spell
this time
it's your last warning turn away from
your screen unless you want to be
affected
this one is one to get your wish
fulfilled so what's something you really
want to happen
i want to get a big juicy part in a big
tv show this year all right
let's do it spread spread man's hoax
five tumble spread
man's hawk fight
spread man
[Music]
all right and editors have a lot of fun
putting graphics to each of those words
that's what he said then
okay we'll see all right those are
the real books tommy how do you feel
pretty good pretty in tune with the dark
universe
pretty magical so i'm ready for magic
love romance power deception
monsters angels demons it's all in dan
brown's new book
tommy's choice it's dan brown's first
adventure to choose your own adventure
genre
but where's the elderly nude no that
happens the next day and let me tell you
it's nudes plural anyway let's talk
about one of our sponsors you you've got
some questions after this but uh uh real
quick helping us bring you big question
is raycon
one of our favorite ways to unwind take
a break from all these
screens is to put some freaking raycon
wireless earbuds
in my ear holes go out for a walk listen
to something great
you could be catching up on your
favorite podcast like this one
uh or you could be binging an audio book
or you could be
rocking out through a workout tommy you
know what that's about
oh you know i do lebron james's revenge
mix on spotify as my personal favorite
uh but a lot of times i also when i'm
just doing cardio i do the hamilton
soundtrack
which is a lot of fun till it gets to a
sad song and then i'm crying while i'm
doing cardio which is something that
used to just happen anyway
well you should try it with a pair of
raycons in your ears that make all the
difference
uh when i when i walk the dog i catch up
on
on my podcast forever raycons are super
comfortable they're stapling ears while
you move
i also they have a freaking six hour
battery life which is five and a half
more hours and i want to be on a walk
uh but i'm covered there either way
recons come in a range of stylish colors
but always uh they have that comfortable
in-ear fit for a more discreet look
they're built to perform anywhere and
anytime with water and sweat resistant
construction
and bluetooth that pairs quickly and
seamlessly the best part
is that raycon makes great sound
accessible to everyone with wireless
earbuds starting at
half the price of other premium audio
brands if you're wondering where
my recons are right now my other half is
wearing them
uh and won't give them back raycon's
offering 15 off all their products for
our audience and here's what you got to
do to get it you just go to
buy raycon dot com slash big question
that's it i
it sounds like it's gonna be more
complicated than that buy raycon.com
bigquestion you get 15 off your entire
recon order
feel free to grab a pair and a spare one
if you want that's 15 off by
big question all right tommy you ready
to
jump into some bite size i'm ready to
take a bite out of these bite size
questions yum yum yum yum
yummy yummy gonna eat yeah tommy
this is this is a important question uh
i've had it the world has had it iaj
smith24
discord has had it everybody's wondering
we all gotta know
tommy how much does wolverine weigh um
uh okay according to marvel's own
dictionary it's none of your goddamn
business
why did you look up his weight in a
dictionary uh because it's marvel's own
dictionary and it's the only dictionary
i allow in my house
not webster's fraud dictionary not
dictionary of
bar drinks that i used to have during my
drinking days no
i only have marvel's own dictionary and
by the way my drinking days are ongoing
so don't start any rumors on the
internet about sobriety over here
jack anyway why did you have so many
dictionaries
and why do you look up weights in them
what are you doing
i was a bit of a [ __ ] back then
that's what we call dictionary fans
uh dick [ __ ] uh anyway
wolverine weighs about 300 pounds 136
kilograms for you canadian [ __ ] he
weighed 195
before he was given his adamantium
skeleton which added at 105 pounds so
let's put it this way
even with an enhanced skeleton made of
adamantium i still
weigh more than wolverine with just this
human skin this means that just the thin
as i said the thin adamantium coating
over his 5'3 skeleton
it's 105 pounds to his overall weight if
you want me to do the math for you i
will that increases his weight by 46
the general rule of thumb which we
learned in boondock saints is an
inappropriate thing to say because it's
how you measure the stick you could beat
your wife with remember that a general
policy is about 15
of your body weight is bone mass so
replacing all of your bones with
titanium
which is about three times as dense as
bone would only increase wolverine's
weight by about
60 pounds which shows how dense
adamantium is that just a layer of it
over bones increases weight by almost
double that so that's some dense ass
metal that's some damn that's some damn
adamantium on your bones that's some
damn that's some damn
i'm so glad that you're returning back
to la so that your mother doesn't have
to listen to you in the other room
she's she's watching a dvr'd episode of
jeopardy crying into a bowl of popcorn
right now
my son is a failure oh what about
hugh jackman though that that version
has to be different hugh jackman whose
fans are called jackoffs
uh is six foot two and lean and mean at
181 pounds the comics wolverine
is much more stocky and muscular his bmi
of 34.5
would actually qualify him to get a
covid vaccine right now
and also make him obese the comics do a
good job of justifying his muscular
frame by saying that his healing factor
allows him to recover from workouts much
faster than normal people thus
allowing him to build more muscle and
strength unlike me who requires
days days of recovery after a simple
bench press exercise to have the same
bmi as wolverine at hugh jackman's
height he would need to weigh 269 pounds
without the adamantium skeleton and
probably close to
400 pounds with the adamantium does that
make him
the greatest grow man do you wanna go
okay we said that you would never say
every night i lie
in bed really sad cause i'm not dead
i've been alive since before the civil
war
saber-tooth might be my brother i've
never
met my real mother bones come out of my
hands every night
sorry mom she's really crying it's
really gonna show up on the microphone
she's crying pretty hard right now
uh okay so that would be 25 pounds
heavier than the average nfl linebacker
at the same
height so anyway just to put a button on
this uh
the common fan casting of taryn edgerton
is he's fi
people want to see him as wolverine he's
five 974 pounds
lay off all the cookies elton so we need
to gain almost 60 pounds to be
proportional to the comic books version
of wolverine so taran maybe start eating
the cookies elton you're
still snacking and eating all the chips
ahoy
it's a really musical episode it's
really one-sided on that
it doesn't have to be tommy it's time to
wrap this episode up this has been a
disaster as always okay
great great great great we got a box of
scraps question here
what was a book you owned or borrowed
that you were very afraid
someone would discover you were reading
well that would be
a thing that actually happened to me uh
one summer i just read the whole summer
and the hot books out at that point were
the twilight saga
and i bought all of them and read all of
them and not only
i didn't buy them on amazon i bought
them all full price at barnes noble so
like
32.99 per book so that's like one of
their five books
that's like a hundred and it's like 150
worth of twilight books
so i would say and then what what ended
up happening is i moved
and i was putting things up and i feel
like i set them
aside and we had people over and someone
saw my stack of twilight books and
it became a running bit forever that i
uh
i owned the twilight novels mom
is still so proud though
god my poor mom i i borrowed i i
was smart enough not to buy it do you
remember neil strauss's the game
that was my runner up my my roommate had
it and he kept it in the bathroom and i
read it
because of that and it was shameful to
own that man
it well when i read it it was in college
for those of you that don't know
uh this is a book that tells you
basically how to seduce women yeah and
it's kind of like got some good tips
actually in there where you're like uh
you know you should be more confident
women are attracted to that
that you know some of them harnessed for
the powers of good
are helpful like yeah believe in
yourself and like don't be afraid to
talk to an attractive girl
don't tell yourself you have no chance
with her like go for it and you never
know what's gonna happen
and then okay then it starts getting
into problematic territory where it's
still talking about nagging women and it
and it's like yes
all right if a girl is pretty make her
feel ugly you know really put her in her
place
and then she'll be more attracted to you
and then it gets to a really weird thing
where it gets into the concept of
neuro-linguistic programming where you
you can brainwash a girl to
need to get with you uh like physically
by using some like pseudo magic moves
and you
reprogram her brain you scramble her
nars
to girls have nerds wolf man has smarts
that's for sure
then she she needs to get with you you
you really created a complicated image
in my head
of mystery scrambling wolf man's dark
hey you're pretty hairy way hairier than
any wolf man i'd ever date
you like my giant fur hat i can't
believe he's nagging the wolf man
um and so i so i had this and i felt uh
uh really bad about where
it eventually gets but i will say
since then books i do not feel bad about
are about
pleasing uh the other sex and they're
online oh yeah bookshelf right there and
there's a lot of uh
positive things you can do still
physically even
uh but uh they're not mean so don't read
that
read she comes first instead uh
it is a much better tome
if you will yes a book about hope in my
opinion
a book about hope yeah the the magic you
can do with your tongue
uh speaking spells of course
yes speaking in tongues yeah all right
guys also a quick shout out to
our friends over at stereo it's that app
that lets users listen in
seek out topics and then you join the
conversation about whatever is your idea
uh that interests you comedy pop culture
sports whatever we do
shows on there talking about uh nerd
news me and eric do that on wednesdays
the editors
do some tea spilling on monday mornings
and then inside marvel
uh is records live uh friday mornings
with jessica and eric and you never know
when i'm going to go live on there just
to
announce something or i have a stereo
account i want to harness it for
something
uh and stereo can be downloaded free by
apple and android users once you
download the app you create a little
avatar and profile and you can uh
make them look like you are not like you
then you can go live yourself you can
also submit audio messages to the host
of the conversation so we've been doing
a q a show
uh on there and also that's how you take
your inside marvel conversations you do
it in real time some of this
stuff by the way is exclusive to stereo
like the uh q and a stuff that eric and
i are doing on there
um catch our new shows on stereo every
monday wednesday and friday go to stereo
dot com slash new rockstars to get all
the details
and get notified when we go live against
stereo dot com slash new rockstars
tommy it's been a delight a joy
a musical uh journey through the stars
i i wish i could rewrite the stars so i
could be with you
wow that's the nicest thing anyone's
ever said to me bye everybody
bye
[Music]
you